this is some like Instagram model baking
is a makeup technique that was invented
by drag queens to make their makeup stay
on their faces longer a lot of celebrity
makeup artists have been doing it to big
celebrities like Kim Kardashian and I
don't know more than any other
celebrities that matter the heat from
your face mixing with the oils it comes
through your skin and it takes about 10
minutes for the whole process to happen
and that's how you get baked in order to
bake your face you need a liquid
concealer Beauty Blender soft brushes
translucent powder sponges I thought
baking was just applied to like making
capes you have something very hot near
your face like a lava lamp a makeup
thing that involves a lot of makeup and
like a decent amount of time part of it
is that I'm a little bit intimidated by
makeup I mean look at this this is
terrifying
my mom says things to me like it
wouldn't kill you to wear some blush
once in a while I just don't think I can
do anything on my face with any level of
precision but we'll see we'll see I you
know I've come full of surprises the
other day I ate a banana and I don't
like bananas
step 1 apply liquid concealer under your
eyeballs and then you put it here on you
you put it they look pretty yet this is
actually kind of like therapeutic I feel
like a five-year-old he didn't put any
on here mustache but I've come along to
blend this by just pressing it into my
skin in sort of a beating motion like
beep just out of their own space and
then you take a undescended testicle and
rub it in the first thing I'm concerned
about when I wake up is like where's
breakfast and like is there something
clean enough for me to wear to work help
exactly look like she looks so at this
point you want to take your
Beautyblender or your triangular sponge
and you are going to dip it into the
translucent powder and apply it all over
where you put that concealer and that's
really where the baking technique comes
in now I'm looking more and more like a
mime so for oily or skin types you're
actually going to see those oils coming
out through the translucent powder so
that's where the term bacon comes from
that's how you know you're cook and now
we bake while you're waiting for your
face to bake it would be a good time to
finish the rest of your routine
put your eyebrows on fleek maybe pour
yourself a nice last rose day if you
look closely at my skin you can see that
my natural oils have sort of like
blended a little bit with the powder and
I haven't even like touched it with a
brush and that's pretty cool
I like to use a clean blush brush or a
eyeshadow brush so I'm just gonna go
ahead and go right in here and make up
videos everyone makes this face we just
do a lot of this when they're doing it
so that's I don't have to make this face
I just want to capture the aesthetic she
makes it look like there's like a Grace
on art to the brushstroke this looks
crazy looks like an old ghost and it's
that easy
inviting like not easy it like it's fun
to have like weird it on your face and
just to be able to play clay with
brushes and just make yourself look a
little bit more done up than you
normally would this is probably the one
makeup style where I could actually see
myself doing this it takes a lot of time
and it's not particularly pleasant it's
like I don't like breathing in powder
and like sitting with tons of makeup on
my face I think if you're
to it like great just not for me
when I see other kinds of makeup you
kind of sometimes it feels like you lose
the person and it's like it looks like
them but it's not them whereas like I
look at this and I'm like oh I still see
me and I like me so it's good to see me